[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء توقع الاطراف
الليبيه غدا الخميس برعايه الامم المتحده
على اتفاق يهدف الى حل الازمه وسيوقع على
الاتفاق بحسب ما اعلن في مدينه الخيرات
بالمغرب بحضور عدد من اعضاء المؤتمر
الوطني العام ومجلس النواب المنحل في طبرق
ولكن وقبل ساعات من هذا الموعد قال
المتحدث باسم المؤتمر الوطني عمر حميدان
ان المؤتمر لم يفوض احدا لا بالمشاركه ولا
بالتوقيع نيابه عنه يوم غد نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي حقيقه الاتفاق من عدمه بين
اطراف الازمه
الليبيه وماذا عن فرص استكمال التوافق
بشان الاتفاق المقرر توقيعه غدا وافاق
تطبيقه اذا عشيه التوقيع المقرر على اتفاق
ينهي الازمه الليبيه برزت مواقف رافضه
لمضمون الاتفاق الذي ترعاه الامم المتحده
وقد اعلن المؤتمر الوطني موا جديده قد
تغير الكثير من ملامح الصوره المرتقبه
للقاء صخرات يوم غد وبما يفتح الباب على
تساؤلات عده بشان مستقبل الازمه الليبيه
نتابع يعلن المؤتمر الوطني العام انه لم
يفوض احدا من اعضائه لا بالمشاركه ولا
بالتوقيع في اللقاء المزمع عقده في
الصخيرات بالمغرب ثلاثه يؤكد المؤتمر الو
الوطني العام على ان ان فرض مخرجات غير
متفق عليها سي يؤدي الى زياده تعقيد
المشهد السياسي
الليبي الصخرات المغرب المكان هو الامر
الوحيد المحسوم في شان توقيع اتفاق نهائي
للتسويه السياسيه بين اطراف النزاع في
ليبيا اتفاق دولي ترفضه اطراف مهمه في
الداخل وتقول ان كثيرا من تفاصيله
الجوهريه غامضه وفيه استعجال ينتهي بتجميع
التناقضات بدلا من حلها في مضمون الخطه
التي تصفها الامم المتحده باتفاق تاريخي
اقامه حكومه وحده تضم الطرفين المتنازعين
المؤتمر الوطني العام وليد الثوره الاول
وحامل لواء الدفاع عنها وبرلمان طبرق
المنحل الذي انتجته اول انتخابات تشريعيه
ابطلتها المحكمه الدستوريه ومع ذلك ظل
يحظى باعتراف المجتمع الدولي لا يحسم
الاتفاق الشرعيه السياسيه او الدستوريه
ولا من سيمسك بالامن والجيش ولا مصير قائد
ما تسمى بعمليه الكرامه خليفه حفتر ومن
معه ويتحدث عن ضروره مكافحه افه الارهاب
ذلك نفسه ابرز ما خلص اليه اجتماع روما
الدولي الاسبوع الفائت وتصدره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي حيث قال ان ليبيا لا
يمكن ان تستمر على هذا النحو لان الارهاب
هناك يشكل خطرا على العالم من جديد اذا
الكلمه المفتاح او صاعق التفجير الذي يفتح
اشكاليه على مستوى العالم كله ما هو تعري
الارهاب وتصنيفه ومعاييره وما الذي يضمن
ان لا تختلط مفاهيمه بحسب رؤيه الاطراف
الاقليميه والدوليه فتصبح جماعات الثوار
التي قاتلت نظام القذافي وتسيطر الان على
معظم الارض في ليبيا مثلا ضمن تعريفه او
لوائحه اللبس الكامن في مصطلحات مبهمه
يمتد ايضا براي كثيرين الى قفز اخر فوق
حقيقه ان ليبيا هي ساحه صراع مشاريع
اقليميه وهو ما عانى منه الليبي كثيرا في
زمن المبعوث الاول برناردينو ليون
ومبادراته وقد انتهى الى وظيفه مجزيه في
دوله يقول ليبيون انها متدخله بقوه في
خلافاتهم هذه المنطلقات من بين ما دفع
رئيس المؤتمر الوطني نوري بوسهمين ورئيس
برلمان طبرق المنحل عقي صالح لرفض الاتفاق
المستعجل كما وصفاه خلال اجتماع نادر
ضمهما في مالطا يرى الرجلان واخرون ان
احتياج ليبي للاستقرار لا يجب ان ينتهي
باتفاق ياتي كيف ما اتفق وان تقارب
الليبيين ممكن اكثر ربما لو تركوا وشانهم
واتفاق تونس قبل ايام
دليل وموضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين من
طرابلس محمود عبد العزيز عضو المؤتمر
الوطني العام ومن باريس مع الكاتب الصحفي
الليبي كامل المرعاش وابدا مع سيد عبد
العزيز من طرابلس سيد عبد العزيز لماذا
حتى الساعات الاخيره يعني عشيه الموعد
المتفق عليه للتوقيع على الاتفاق في
الصخيرات يعلن عمر حميدان ان المؤتمر لم
يفوض احدا التحدث باسمه او التوقيع باسمه
على اتفاق من هذا النوع لماذا
الان طبعا الان لان الحقيقه يعني ما
سمعناه من المبعوث الاممي مارتن كوبلر بعد
زيارته لطرابلس منذ حدود ثلاث اسابيع او
يزيد قليلا ان اراده المؤتمر الوطني العام
يمثلها
الاقليه فجاءت جلسه اليوم وايضا بالامس
سمعنا منه هذا الكلام عندما كنا في مالطا
في لقاء الرئيسين السيد عجيله صالح والسيد
نوري
بوسهمين سمعنا هذا الكلام من السيد كوبلر
وبالتالي جاء اي جاءت جلسه المؤتمر
الوطني اليوم واضحه جليه منقوله على
الهواء مباشره سامعها كل الليبيين ربما
قناه الجزيره ايضا نقلت جزء منها حضرها
مراقبين من مؤسسات المجتمع المدني ومن
رجال الاعلام والصحافه وكانت اراده
المؤتمر واضحه اجماع من الاعضاء الحاضرين
بالكامل على ان الحوار الليبي الليبي هو
الخيار بعد وضوح الرؤيه
بعد رؤيتنا لان المبعوث الاممي سواء برنان
دينو اليون وهذا كنا نشك فيه ولكن فضيحه
الجارديان كانت مدويه جليه ولم يرد السيد
بانكيمون على رساله رئيس المؤتمر الوطني
العام ل تجليه هذا الموضوع ثم استمرار
السيد مارتن كوبلر الذي جاء الى طرابلس
وسمعنا منه كلاما طيب ثم خرج خارج طرابلس
وقال اننا لن نفتح تلك المس سوده وسوف
ننطلق الى الامام ايضا يصر على كل مخرجات
برنان دينو ليون حقيقه شعرنا بالاهانه
شعرنا تخيل يعني العالم كله اقر بان هناك
دعنا طبعا انا ليست شبهه بالنسبه لي اكيده
واكدها برنان دينو اليون في مؤتمر صحفي ان
في في شهر اغسطس الماضي وهو على راس مهمته
ومن قبل حتى تشكيل الحكومه يتعاقد مع
الامارات على بعقد ضخم جدا 1000 باوند في
اليوم مع مزايا رهيبه جدا لا يمكن انطح
فيزيز هذه المعطيات ليست جديده بالنسبه
اليكم هذه المعطيات ليست جديده بالنسبه
اليكم والوافد الذي كان يفاوض كان قد ذهب
على اعتبار انه من المؤتمر الوطني الان
يجد نفسه عاريا هناك يعني هل هل سيوقع غدا
ام لن يوقع هل سيعود هل هناك انقسام في
الم
ما الذي
سيحصل هذه المعلومه خاطئه اخي لم يذهب
الوفد انه موفد من المؤتمر رئيس فريق
الحوار الدكتور عود عبد الصادق
معه بقيه فريق الحوار الاستاذ محمد بقي
الدكتور محمد العماري الدكتور عبد الرحمن
السويحلي هم
المفوضين بالحوار من ذهبوا الى تونس ليسوا
هؤلاء اخي ذهب شخصيات غير مفوضه ذهب
شخصيات لا اربعه خمس شهور لم تحضر جلسات
اساسا ام فهم وبالتالي هم غير مخولين هذه
المعلومه لو سمحت اخي غير صحيحه التي
ذكرتها من ذهب الى تونس بالمره لم نعلم
عليهم حتى رايناهم في الاعلام بالعكس
استغربنا ودخلنا معهم في نقاش فقالوا نحن
ذهبنا من كيف انفسنا يعني تخيل يعني ماشي
يمثل فيين وفي المؤتمر الوطني يمثل في
اراده الشعب الليبي في اراده 17 فبراير من
كيفه وبالتالي انا اري رييد ان اصح هذه
المعلومه من ذهب من هو موجود اليوم في
الصخيرات لا يمثل السيد مارتن كوبلر سوق
له او هو حاول ان يسوق كما قلت الى الى
العديد من الاطراف الدوليه نحن على اتصال
باطراف دوليه عديده جدا عربيه وغير عربيه
عربيه افريقيه دوليه قالوا ان لو سمحتم
انتم تمثلون اقليه فقلنا لهم غدا سوف نرجع
الى طرابلس ونعقد جلسه وبالفعل نحن سلنا
لهم توقيع 90 عضو من المؤتمر الوطني العام
فقالوا هذه التوقيعات ممكن ان تكون طبعا
انا متاكد للاسف انا اقولها بمنتهى
الشفافيه ان بعض الليبيين يسوق لهم هذه
الاكاذيب
جلسنا اليوم في المؤتمر منقول على الهواء
التصويت واضح جدا التسجيلات موجوده نقلتها
فضائيات عديده ثم خرج بيان المؤتمر الوطني
المصوت عليه بالاجماع ان من ذ ذب للصخيرات
لا يمثل المؤتمر ان المجتمع الدولي يجب ان
يقف امام مسؤوليه اتجاه المشكل الليبي وان
الحوار يجب ان يكون ليبي ليبي نتقابل اذا
اذا هذا الموضوع اصبح وا نحن
الليبيون فاما ان نحل المشكل نعم هذا اصبح
اصبح واضحا
وجليا سيد كامل المرعاش هل اذا نحن امام
بدايه فشل للاتفاق الذي من المزمع توقيعه
غدا في الخراط فشل يعني حتى لو وقع لن يجد
من ينفذه على ارض الواقع اذا اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار موقف المؤتمر الوطني الذي سمعناه
الان وايضا اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار موقف
رئيسي البرلمانين
اي بعد اجتماعهما في
مالطا يا سيدي القضيه انه
رئاستي سواء البرلمان او المؤتمر الوطني
العام او مؤتمر الميليشيات لديها مصلحه
واحده وهنا اسمي الاشياء بمسمياتها وهو
زواج المصلحه كنا نعرف منذ التوصل الى
اتفاق الخرات ان رئاسه البرلمان كانت
تتهرب من جلسه تصويت على مخرجات الصخرات
وبعد ان تم توقيع ا 90 نائبا بالموافقه
على مخرجات الخرات رئيس البرلمان بدا
يماطل ويبطئ في هذه الجلسات ولا نعرف
بالضبط ماذا في راس السيد عقيله صالح الذي
يبدو انه انشغل في الفتره الاخيره ليس
بهموم ليبيا وانما بالسفر والترحال الى
اقاص دنيا هذه واحده اما بالنسبه لمؤتمر
الميليشيات في طرابلس ف فهو نعرف موقفه
فهو لم يوقع على اي مسوده من المسودات
التسع رغم ان وفده في التفاوض كان موجودا
وكان برئاسه السيد نائب رئيس البر المؤتمر
الوطني العام صالح المخزوم الذي بدا ينعت
اليوم بصالح المهزوم يعني فاوض باسم
المؤتمر لمده عام كامل ثم وصل الى قناعه
ان هذا الاتفاق هو افضل ا حال من ان تبقى
ليبيا على ما هي عليه ثم مجموعه بسيطه في
رئاسه المؤتمر الوطني العام ومن خلفها هي
التي عطلت ايضا التصويت في داخل المؤتمر
الوطني العام ونحن نعرف ان هناك اكثر من
60 نائبا في المؤتمر الوطني العام وكتله
السييد بقاسم قزيط هي مع الوفاق اذا هناك
زواج للمصلحه وسمعنا اخيرا عن هذه
المسرحيه هزيله التي تقول الحوار ليبي
ليبي نعم اذا كان هذا مفهوم الحوار ليبي
ليبي لماذا اراقت كل هذه الدماء لماذا كنا
نتنا بز بالالقاب لماذا الساده في طرابلس
ينعتون طبرق بانه منحل وانه انقلابي وانه
وانه لماذا كل هذه الدماء يا اخي اذا كان
هو الحوار ليبي ليبي لماذا لم يبداوا فليش
حوا لنا هذه النقطه التي امام الليبين طيب
واضح اريد ان اعرف الان باختصار سي كامل
المرعاش اذا كنت
تسمعني تهم مصلحه ليبيا قدر ما تهم
مصلحتهم سيد كامل اريد منك باختصار
الان ان ان تقول لي برايك هل طار التوقيع
يوم غد ام سيحصل التوقيع ولكن سيعلن ان
هناك اتفاق من دون ان يكون هناك من ينفذ
اريد اجابه عمليه على هذا
الموضوع الاجابه العمليه يا سيدي الفاضل
هذا التوقيع سيحصل وسيعرف المجتمع الدولي
وهي هذه النتيجه الايجابيه الوحيده سيعرف
الليبيون حتى قبل المجتمع الدولي من يعرقل
الحوار من يريد استمرار حاله الازمه
وتفاقمها من يريد استمرار القتل ونهب
المال العام في ليبيا من هو المستفيد يجب
ان يشار اليهم بالاصبع هؤلاء هم من يعقل
الم ساتابع معك هذا النقاش ابقى معي ابقى
معي ساتابع معك هذا النقاش ولكن ولكن اريد
اريد ان اذهب الى فاصل اريد ان اذهب الى
فاصل اواصل بعده النقاش مع ضيفي من كل من
باريس وطرابلس مشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا واعود الى
ضيفي ل مناقشه الاتفاق المزمع توقيعه غدا
في مدينه الخيرات الاتفاق الليبي في ضوء
معارضه المؤتمر الوطني الليبي لهذا
الاتفاق اعود الى عضو المؤتمر الوطني من
طرابلس محمود عبد العزيز سيد محمود اولا
ما هي التحفظات التي دفعت المؤتمر الوطني
الى رفض هذا الاتفاق والى ايضا القول ان
من ذهب لا يمثل المؤتمر
الوطني سؤال جميل بس قبل ان اجيبه لا اسمح
لهذا الجالس في في باريس ان يتفوه بكلمه
نابيه عن الدكتور المحترم
اي الدكتور صالح المخزوم هو عضو محترم
النائب الثاني لرئيس المؤتمر اذا نحن من
يخطئه او يصوبه ولكن ان لا اسمح على
الهواء مباشره ان يتجر اي مخلوق
وخاصه من ظل وفيا ل لا نريد ان ندخل في في
شخصنا ولكن هذه الحقيقه لا اسمح لاحد ان
يستهزئ بنائب اختير في اول انتخابات حره
واذا كان من يخطئ هم زملائه ايضا
المنتخبين بوفق الاليات المعتمده في
المؤتمر ولكن لا يمكن لهذا الاستهانه
بممثلي الشعب الذي حدث قبل قليل من من
يحدثنا من باريس اما لسؤالك اخي الكريم
المؤتمر الوطني الياته واضحه جدا نحن
لدينا ملاحظات حاولنا اقناع السيد برنان
دينو اليون اثبتنا للعالم كامل اننا جادين
في الحوار اصدرنا قرارات مراسلاتنا واضحه
جدا جدا للسيد بانكيمون لوزراء الخارجيه
للمبعوث السابق برنان دينو اليون بمنتهى
الجلا لدينا
تعديلات للاسف لم يؤخذ بها نحن نراها
جوهريه جدا السيد برنين ليون يوم يقفل
المسوده ويقول انها غير قابله للتعديل
نتفا جا ثاني يوم بان يفتح المسوده
ويعدلها من كيفه لا لا ادري من يمده
بالافكار ولا ياخذ بتعديلات
ام هذا الجانب الاول الجانب الثاني انه لم
يسمح بلقاء الليبيين ابدا وجها لوجه لم
يسمح طول فتره المحادثات الى الان لم يسمح
بلقاء الليبيين كان ياخذ الكلام كان يجلسه
في سبع
غرف متجاور نحن في قاعه المؤتمر الوطني
قلنا هذا لا يجوز ولكن كلنا تحت اسرار
المجتمع الدولي وحتى لا نتهم بتعطيل
الحوار نذهب الى الحوار مع تعديلات نذهب
الى الحوار مع ملاحظاتنا ولكن للاسف للاسف
لم تؤخذ ملاحظاتنا بعين الاعتبار ثم فجاه
تفاجانا بفضيحه الجارديان وكانت كما يعلم
الجميع غير مسبوقه في تاريخ الامم المتحده
ام
هذا لهذا السبب نحن طيب اذا لم يؤخذ لم
يؤخذ بتح بعثه الامم المتحده هذا الجانب
الاول نعم عفوا الجانب الثاني
لمحات هل من جانب
اخر نعم الجانب الثاني ما هي الاليات
صحيح الاليات سيدي الفاضل نحن يجتمع
المؤتمر الوطني العام يختار فريق الحوار
بناء على تصويت داخل القاعه او تفويض
رئاسه المؤتمر في ذلك ويذهب فريق الحوار
نعلن عنه في في وسائل الاعلام ويذهب فريق
الحوار برساله مختومه ومصدق عليها الى
نرسلها للسيد بانكيمون نرسلها للسفراء
البي ف الدول الكبرى نرسلها لاعضاء مجلس
الامن نرسلها لمبعوث الامم المتحده
بالتالي هذه الرساله لم تصدر من المؤتمر
حتى يذهب فريق الحوار التالي مع احترامنا
الكامل لكل الزملاء الذين هم ذهبوا الى
الصخيرات ولكن نحن نقول وفق اليات
الديمقراطيه المتبعه وفق اللوائح الداخليه
للمؤتمر الوطني العام هؤلاء غير
مخولين طيب ب اريدد ان اسالك هنا اريد ان
اسالك هنا ما ما الذي جمع الان السيد نوري
ابو سهمان مع السيد صالح
عقيله عندما اصبح التوقيع على الاتفاق قاب
قوسين او وهما مختلفان على مدى اشهر واكثر
ما الذي جمعهما الان ايه مصلحه صحيح هو لا
الاختلاف يزي الاختلاف يزيد عن
السنه سؤال جميل جدا وهنا يجب ان اقول
الاتي
طبعا لا انتم تعلمون تركيبه المجتمع
الليبي كان هناك الخيرين من ابناء المجتمع
الذين يعرفون تفاصيل الحوار وان براندين
اليون لم يسمح ابدا بلقاء الاطراف الليبيه
سبب امتعاض لدينا علائق اجتماعيه زملاء
دراسه نحن في المؤتمر الوطني لدينا زملاء
واصدقاء في مجلس النواب اجتمع قبل حدود
شهر 12 ز 12 من نواب
برقه من 12 من المؤتمر الوطني العام و1 من
مجلس النواب اجتمعوا في تونس كانت ما صدر
عنهم في تونس البند الاخير يجب بالحرف يجب
على رئيسي المؤتمر الو الطني العام ومجلس
النواب الاسراع في اللقاء وتولوا هم
التنسيق ثم هذا الكلام منذ اكثر من شهر ثم
اجتمعوا 5 ز خ وبالتالي كان التواصل بين
الرئيسين عرضت مدينه جادو للقاء عرضت ولكن
للاسف لاسباب لوجستيه غدامس عرضت القطرون
عرض
احد الى
ولكن نعم طيب بالضبط وصلنا اخيرا الى
مالطا وكان اللقاء ايجابي جدا نعم طيب
ايجابي و ويعول عليه لحوار ليبي ليبي لكن
سييد كامل المرعاش انت قلت ان الاتفاق
سيوقع غدا طيب ل ليظهر للمجتمع الدولي من
الذي يعرقل كما تقول ولكن لو وقع الاتفاق
وحصل ان انشئ حكومه بالفعل بحسب ما ينص
الاتفاق وهناك من يرفضه صالح عقيله ونوري
ابو سهمين يرفضان اذا نحن سيناريو حكومه
ثالثه الا تساهم هنا الامم المتحده في
تعقيد الازمه اللير والبرلمان وليس اشخاص
نعم طبعا انا اتحدث هنا بالصفه الرسميه
نعم لا ير نعم اتحدث بالصفه الرسميه سيد
كامل
المرعاش الامم المتحده الا تزيد من تعقيد
الازمه بهذا
الشكل نعم دعني اولا ارد على الذي يتحدث
من طرابلس المخطوفه ويتكلم عن الولاءات
فعليه ان يسال نفسه اين كان ولاءه وا اين
اصبح ولاه ولا ازيد عن ذلك ان الليبيون
يعرفون ذلك ثانيا السؤال المهم هو التوقيع
حتى ولو حصل التوقيع انا قلت انه امام
الشعب الليبي الان وهو الذي معني بهذه
القضيه هؤلاء الذين يعرقلون الاتفاق
يريدون استمرار هذه الحاله التي عليها
ليبيا لانهم يتعايشون عليها وهم من يستفيد
منها لا يستفيد منها الليبيون الذين قطعت
عنهم الدراسه وقطعت عنهم المرتبات ويعيشون
في اوضاع مزريه للغايه ونصفهم مهجر في
الداخل والخارج
وحالتهم حاله بؤس تامه هؤلاء لا يرون حال
الليبيين لان اوضاعهم ومزاياهم الماليه
ومرتباتهم العاليه هي التي يبحثون عليها
ويستمرون ويترددون بها ويستعينون في ذلك
بالميليشيات التي انشاتم وقدمتهم في هذه
المراكز حقيقه انا اسمي ذلك زواج مصلحه
ليس الا والتوقيع سيتم وانا لم اشر
للدكتور صالح المخزوم باي اشاره انا انقل
فقط ما تنقله قنوات ميليشيات طرابلس
وضيفك الذي يتحدث منس المخطوفه يعرف هذه
الفضائيات التي تنعته
بالزوم لم لم يبقى لدي المزيد من الوقت
لهذه لهذا النقاش
فق ان نعرف
الا تعريه هؤلاء للمجتمع الدولي ولشعب
الليبي نعم طيب سيد محمود عبد العزيز ما
هو السيناريو الاقرب بالنسبه ال الذي يمكن
ان يحصل في ضوء هذه المواقف
المتناقضه بكل تاكيد نحن اخي نعلم ان
الازمه الليبيه ليست سهله نحن نعلم ان
الانقلاب على ثورات الربيع العربي واضح
وجلي نحن لا نتكلم في فوق القمر او في
عواصم اوروبيه نتكلم من داخل عروس البحر
الابيض المتوسط طرابلس الحبيبه نتجول في
شوارعها ونجلس في مقاهيها و
و نتسوق من اسواقها وبالتالي كل شيء بين
ايدينا نعلم معاناه المواطن نعلم ان صناعه
كتابه التاريخ وصناعه الامم لا تاتي
بسهوله نعلم ان لاخي الليبيين ظلوا من
1911 الى
1931 وهم يقارعون الايطاليين وهم في بؤس
وجوع وخوف نهضه الامم وصناعه التاريخ لا
تك لا يكتبه المرتعش تمر الامم بازمات
ولكن في بر جالها
بثباتهم باصرار على مبادئهم تصنع الامم
ويكتب التاريخ نحن نحس بمعاناه المواطن
ولكن ثابتين على المبدا وباذن الله الحوار
ليبي ليبي وباذن الله لن تنتهي هذه السنه
الا باخبار طيبه ولن نحتفل بعيد الاستقلال
يوم 24 ديسمبر الا ورؤوسنا مرفوعه
وابتسامه كما شاهدها العالم البارحه في
ميدان الشهداء تين الله اك نعم اشكرك
جزيلا عضو المؤتمر الوطني العام حدثنا من
طرابلس واشكر من باريس المحلل السياسي
الليبي كامل المرعش شكرا شكرا لمتابعتكم
مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله
ه